[Music]
the review
main review
[Music]
welcome everyone to the most esteemed
meme review show on the planet what are
the latest memes you need to know you
come to the right place first me if
these are bad you can blame scythe
because saiv is the one that sent it to
me first off we have drake memes
director's kind of rapper that if
someone says drake is my favorite rapper
i will forever judge you and we can
never be friends drake that type of
bloke that say geronimo
then who
is fall into the pool
let's go this is an older meme i've
definitely seen this before but uh this
is very funny drake the type of n-word
to eat two gummy bears at a time so they
don't die alone this one i actually
don't have a problem with i think that's
quite generous this is called empathy
[ __ ] drake the kind of n word to kiss a
stripper on her forehead and whisper
this isn't you then walk away damn hey i
mean i feel it i feel like drake the
kind of the type of n-word to stare at
you while you sleep and not blink
because he's worried that if he does
you'll disappear or some other sensitive
yeah that is some sensitive light skin
oh sh
drake the type of dude who say wakey
wakey eggs
yes it's funny because it is uh wakey
wakey time to pinky drank the type of
dude who say mean
me me mean what what
okay good job scythe these are hilarious
drake the type of bloke thank you for
censoring it to wiggle his fingers and
say don't mind if i do at the side of
donuts
don't mind if i do drake is the type of
guy to eat pizza with fork and no
no
it's totally fine it's fine it's fine
everyone should have you tried it i
posted on my instagram where is it oh my
god this is so stupid i posted on my
instagram enjoying yummy pizza pizza
time thinking wow i'm gonna share this
delicious pizza yummy pizza time and
then i posted that i ate the pizza
mmm so delicious and everyone got mad at
me what did i do i don't get it geez
louise man
you want that [ __ ] drake's the type of
guy that would say louise
he knows he knows he knows okay i kind
of respect him for at least being
self-aware now i appreciate that a lot
actually
god damn it drake the type of n-word to
text another
we're good not a tree
drake the type of guy who danced with a
chick at the club then texture so what
are we that burps in a napkin yeah i do
that what's the problem i'm not gonna
burp outside that's gross
it's funny because kids would always do
this right all right enough enough
enough
enough pewdiepie is the kind of kind of
bloke mate that eats pizza without the
crust yeah cause he's yes because he's
extra beast he knows how to eat the
pizza without the crust all this name
sells eating the pizza crust it's the
worst part of the pizza moving on drake
memes ah solid eight it makes me they
make me [ __ ] laugh right all right
guys nate it's me i just want you to
know feel free to screenshot feel free
to screenshot this cool there's pick go
hard it's cool feel free to screenshot
it you know what i'm actually gonna
screenshot this myself there you go
that's cool i got it saved locked and
loaded here's another pick that goes
hard
this is my hard pick folder harvest or
rescue what will you do why not harvest
and rescue get both strength of the
kitty me looking through the insanely
funny squid game memes posted today yeah
those got old real quick didn't they
how about we see um
paula helen's sweet game memes oh
oh
okay this pick goes hard
feel free to screenshot don't mind if i
do
don't mind if i do switch
oh damn
this pic does go hard i will screenshot
thanks it's a nice squid game meme whoa
it's john karczynski from the office he
goes hard now
yeah bionicle loving a smoke that goes
hard i'm a screenshot but just a
cigarette
so mom doesn't know bionicle smokes
okay what a meme okay all right you got
me i screenshotted it you got me you win
it's not a [ __ ] chupacabra
everyone keep screenshotting i mean he
said it was free to screenshot me when
the meme says free feel free to
screenshot
it's free real estate
all right
two two out of ten this is garbage i
don't know i can't i can't even pretend
this is good i mean does it go hard
absolutely
is it a good meme no absolutely not no
next meme everyone out here being a
goody tooty good shoes like drake right
but what if there was an evil version of
everyone kind of like evil markiplier
what was that called okay we have
markiplier but we also have
darkiplier okay evil modern theme leader
king be like i have a nightmare evil
frank sinatra be like
that's death damn
okay this meme do go hard i will
screenshot it evil yes man be like
no evil backstreet boys be like
backstreet's gone oh no i'm not
screenshotting that that's too much man
evil upgrade scientists be like finally
mambo number four
that's actually good i like that one
no
no not evil bob ross he does not exist
evil bob ross he's real he can hurt you
we don't make accuracies just sad big
intention no
no
no come back to which bob ross come back
to it snap out of it evil beach boys be
like wouldn't it be horrible
nice evil joker be like hello inflation
artist i'd like to commission inflation
art i don't get it
stop it
that's good evil drake be like i like
having sex written
now that's just rude man
there's no abby danes except a bunch of
creepy behavior but you know all right
i'm done this is trash
zara i don't like it i don't like it i
don't like it you can't make me like
something i give it zero it's dead now
you're dead you're done evil darkiplier
no i'm sorry
i'm sorry no no
next name oh what's that
meme news
[Music]
good evening everyone i'm bro borgenburg
in today's meme news new zealand fired
its official wizard after 23 years ian
brackenbury chanel was paid 16 000
a year to perform acts of wizardry like
reign dances making over three grand
three hundred thousand i mean his
contract termination came after he made
misogynistic comments about beating
women our next story comes from mr krabs
mr krab is reporting live at the scene
money money money money
[Applause]
mr krab has just diseased this just in
he's dead
[Music]
speaking of money check out my merch
link in the description see you tomorrow
money money money
thought something would happen